uh Ranger the dog uh which hopefully I
don't know if that's my brother Joe or
or if that's somebody else asks uh what
are the biggest risks Bitcoin faces you
know I think that Bitcoin is in a very
unique position in that um the biggest
risk is actually a internal risk meaning
that I don't worry about
um geopolitical risk I don't worry about
um uh an external hack of Bitcoin or
anything like that I think probably the
biggest risk and I'll caveat this with
saying like it is essentially a zero
percent risk nothing zero percent risk
uh but but it's a very very very low
probability uh is some sort of
self-induced wound Bitcoin is uh
software that software still has uh
people maintaining it it still gets
updated
um and the development process is uh
very much methodical it's intentional uh
it's somewhat slow in order to ensure
but there's nothing uh that ends up
getting broken there's 800 billion
dollars or so of economic value at stake
here and we're trying to build a system
that's going to last for centuries and
so there's no rush
um but just making sure that that
there's no uh you know bug or anything
like that introduced I think is
important obviously as do the developers
um so to me like it's more of like the
balls in our court and uh and we're
likely to make the biggest mistakes uh
another I don't want to say is a risk
but it's something to pay attention to
um is definitely this uh ESG narrative
you see these politicians running around
you score political points for talking
about it but when uh these academic
theories meet reality uh reality wins
and so take New York New York recently
discussed uh this idea of a moratorium
on new miners that aren't 100 renewable
and the politician who put it Forward
said oh everyone's taking this out of
context it's not going to have a bad uh
impact don't worry everyone's freaking
out whatever and I I believe it's a
woman who said uh you know we're not
going to lose economic value because
it's not going to hurt our economy but
at the same time she's saying all this
50 of the miners in New York have left
over the last like year
so it's an academic Theory oh this
doesn't have a big issue we shouldn't
worry about it's not a problem don't
worry uh it's not going to hurt our
economy at the same time 50 of the
miners left so reality meets academic
Theory reality wins and I think that's
an important uh piece of it is like this
ESG narrative it's just a pain in the
ass because we got to deal with it we
gotta answer it gotta talk about it but
what ends up happening is that ESG is a
complete scan the whole thing is just
full of nonsense uh and so naturally I
think reality will win out but the
academic Theory uh is something that has
to be addressed and then the other thing
is uh I still think that taxation uh in
the United States you know if you really
think about especially in the United
States uh if I go to dinner tonight and
I buy dinner with dollars uh I pay for
the price of the meal I tip the waiter
or waitress and I pay sales tax and I
walk out of the restaurant if I buy it
in Bitcoin I end up paying for the price
of the meal I tip the waiter waitress I
pay sales tax and then I pay capital
gains on bitcoin and so naturally
there's a fairly abrasive uh tax
treatment because tree does property and
so I think that that's going to have to
get solved over time so it's not a risk
it's just something that needs to uh
kind of uh be addressed if you will